and I know that there's actually the
black trans movement as well happening
right now like black black trans lives
matter right it's been going on for a
very long time and I think we've just
people are starting to pay attention and
I mean we have a long way to go right
like there's there unfortunately in the
month of June there have been murders of
several trans people all black trans
women well except for one mostly black
trans women this month but also trans
women of trans people of all races and
and genders Toni McDade as a trans man
who was murdered May 27th
on two days after George Floyd and
Tallahassee Florida by two by a police
officers there and so it's a movement
that's been going on for a long time and
there's a tension now then we're under
beginning to understand that when we say
black lives matter that has to include
at all black lives that like we just
because I'm transgender doesn't mean
that I'm not affected by the same racism
that the rest of the world is also
affected by so we're getting there we
have a long way to go in terms of really
being fully inclusive of everyone but
that's that's that's the country that's
the world so yeah but I think I don't
know do you feel hope with what's
happening right now a little bit
sometimes it depends on the day
sometimes I feel like overwhelmed and
I'm like we are never gonna get anywhere
and then other days I feel like you hear
these stories of like just hope and
thing and people doing the right thing
and that makes me hopeful where are you
at politicians don't always give me hope
but the people give me hope seeing I
mean I think after more people than
politicians amen preach so after what
happened to George Floyd I think that if
people hadn't taken to the streets and
hadn't you know mobilized then I would
then I would really feel awful I feel
horrible and I thought you know after
you know we saw my ground and Tamir rice
and Trayvon Martin that something would
change so I have hope because that
people have mobilized and that the
people are not relenting and I think we
need to not relent and we need to
continue to make our demands and I feel
emboldened and inspired by everyone out
there marching to keep marching keep
protesting peacefully and keep spreading
love and awareness and keep demanding
justice subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going